قالت السفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم انها
تواصل مراقبه الوضع في الخرطوم والمناطق
المحيطه بها عن كثب وحثت السفاره مواطنيها
على البقاء في منازلهم حتى اشعار اخر
واكدت انه لا توجد اي خطط لاجلاء
الامريكيين في الوقت الحالي وانها ستعلن
ذلك اذا ما اصبح اجلاء المواطنين ضروريا
[موسيقى]
انما الينا من واشنطن السفير الامريكي
السابق لدى السودان اهلا بك معنا ماذا
نقرا في بيان السفاره الامريكيه لا ترى
بحاجه الان الى دعوه مواطنيها للخروج
والاجلاء
هل هناك درجه من الامان موجوده
تسمح ببقائهم
اعتقد ان نجد ان كل سفاره من سفارات
الموجوده في خرطوم وكل وزاره خارجيه ومنها
الخارجيه لولايه المتحده قد حثت مواطنيها
على البقاء في منازلهم
كاجرائهم امنين لهم واضافه لذلك فان كل
الدول تحث مواطنيها ان لا يسافروا الى
السودان في هذا الوقت
ولك الافراد وامن سلامه الافراد والسفاله
تحرص عليها السفاره هو جزء من عملها
بطبيعه الحال اكثر من
قارئ للمشهد من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا يرى بان لدى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اوراق ضغط في السودان
يمكن ان تتعامل مع هذه الازمه وفي المقابل
تطالب الدول المعنيه في المنطقه باتخاذ
اجراءات معينه هل بالفعل درجه تاثير
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في السودان
قليل لهذه الدرجه
السودان لك مثل كثير من الدول الاخرى
تتصرف حسب ارائها المبنيه على مصالحها
الخاصه الولايات المتحده لا يمكن ان تضع
مصالح السودان
للسودانيين ويسير عليها ولكن رغم ذلك صحيح
ايضا ان الولايات المتحده لديها نفوذ او
تاثير قليل نسبيا على السودان عدا الجوانب
الاقتصاديه والماليه الحكومه السودانيه
تدين للمجتمع الدولي
بكمياء اموال هائله كثيره حوالي 50 مليار
دولار امريكي وان الولايات المتحده حيويه
وضروريه لتقليل وتقليص والتخلص من هذه
الديون بحيث تصبح السودان دور الاكثر جذبا
للناس للقيام بالتجاره
وانشاءه تجاراتنا او شركات جديده وايضا
لتحقيق
الرفاه في هذا البلد
لكن لسوء الحظ
العسكريين الاثنين الان يحاولون يسعنان
يسيطر على السلطه بكاملها اي برهان
وحمايتي الذين لا يهتمان بمصلحه شعبهم ما
بل يهتم منا فقط بالسلطه
واذا ما كانوا يهتمون ببلادهم وشعبهما
لعرفوا انه الان ان الاوان للتوجه الى
اعطاء الحكم للمدنيين هو اعاده العسكر الى
ثكناتهم
وقوات دعم الدعم السريع يجب دمجها مع
الجيش النظامي
والمضي قدما نحو المستقبل ولكن هذا هو ما
لا يحصل حاليا بالنشهد ذلك صراع على
السلطه
كنت سفيرا سابقا لدى السودان وعندما تعطي
ربما
ملاحظات للاداره الامريكيه تعطيها بحسب
قراءتك للمشهد وما يدور على الارض لو كان
بيدك الامر الان ان توجه رساله للبيت
الابيض لاتخاذ اي موقف ماذا كانت ستكون
هذه الرساله
يعجبني سؤالك هذا جدا انا
الجوابي الاساسي هو ان لا يكون مختلفا
كثيرا اما
يحاول يقوم به الوزير الخارجيه بلينكن الا
وهو القول لابد من جعل كل المجتمع الدولي
وخاصه الدول المجاوره للسودان وهذا يشمل
الدول الخليج وكذلك
كينيا واثيوبيا
ومصر
اوغندا لان يجعله طبعا لجنوب السودان ايضا
جعل كل هذه الدول تعمل من اجله جعل الجرار
برهان وحميتي اعادتهما الى عقلهما والى
منطقه الصحيح
والتوقف عن هذا الحرب او النزاع الغير
المجدي والماساوي ايضا من خلال معرفتك
بالمنطقه وتاثير السودان الذي مر واعتقد
انك كنت في فتره
تشاهد الحروب التي كانت حاصله سواء مع
الجنوب ثم بعد ذلك الانفصال الحروب التي
صارت في دارفور الميليشيات التي خرجت من
كل مكان في الجنوب في شمال في الشرق
فبرايك الانزلاق اكثر
نحو الحرب بين
الجهتين الان المتصارعتين في السودان
تاثيره على المنطقه برا واذا اردنا ان
ناخذ وجهه نظر
تاثير استراتيجي بالنسبه ليس فقط للدول
الافريقيه وانما الاقليم
كما تعلمون السودان محاط
كان السابق بتسعه الدول الى ان استقلت
جنوب السودان وبالتالي لكن اعتقد ما زالت
الارض صحيحا
اذا ذلك ان جنوب السودان اصبحت دوله
مستقله
ولكنها تبقى منطقه مركزيه
تحقق الاستقرار للمنطقه اذ تتمتع
بامكانيات زراعيه رائعه كبيره وقد تكون
سله الخبز لكل قاره كل قرن الافريقي بسبب
المياه وبسبب
اراضيها الكثيره والخصبه
وان عدم تحقيق هذه الامكانات الكامنه قد
يعرض كل المنطقه للخطر اذ تحصل مشاكل
مجاعه وسوء توزيع للموارد
وبصراحه
المبالغه وعلى قدر كبير من الفساد مما
يجعل شعوب هذه الدول في شكرا صعب للغايه
وقد يكون عليهم اعتقد يؤثر على الاستقرار
فيها شكرا جزيلا لك السفير الامريكي
السابق لدى السودان تمثي كارني كان معنا
منه واشنطن